amazon just put the entire healthcare
industry on notice with its latest push
into pharmacy here's
who stands to win or lose through amazon
pharmacy customers can shop for drugs
and get them shipped in a mail prime
members can also receive discounts on
the medication
it's part of amazon's slow but steady
entry into the u.s healthcare system
some healthcare companies
like drug wholesalers stand to benefit
as amazon pushes deeper into healthcare
while businesses like retail pharmacies
stand to lose out
as prescriptions go online cvs walgreens
especially smaller right a took hits
to their stocks on tuesday while the
prime savings could very well drive some
incredible volume
to their shops recall that the prime
discounts
work in the brick and mortar pharmacies
too the service
puts amazon in direct competition with
pharmacies that's online business has
already been heard what are your
thoughts
well you know now i know why bezos hated
trump so much because it really makes
sense to have people at home where they
have to buy everything without leaving
the house
it's unbelievable i mean this is
brilliant um cvs's stock fell
8.5 as soon as this was announced
walgreens went down 10.3
and good rx went down 15 it's a 4
trillion
dollar industry wow 4 trillion the the
thing
um are old people going to feel
comfortable i mean what's the percentage
of old people that buy
pharmaceuticals it's probably pretty
high they like this every time i go to
cvs or walgreens it seems like they like
to be in there
and and touching it and feeling it and
talking to their pharmacist
it's just going to be another example of
what amazon wants amazon gets and even
if they get a
what a third of that pie that's a lot of
money i mean of a 4 trillion dollar
industry it's it's unbelievable how
strategic
amazon is and how they get what they
want and how successful they are
perfect segue to my point they are
strategic they are
aggressive and they are relentless
matter of fact kai pulled this up
if you go to relentless.com go to
relentless.com
what comes up oh my god it's amazon
go to relentless.com amazon shows up so
just to put it in mind to put it in
perspective
of how aggressive and relentless
amazon is no matter what sector there
you go there's some proof you go to
relentless.com amazon is there there
they ain't stopping so if you had any
questions of how big amazon wants to get
they are the gorilla in the room and
they want to be the biggest baddest mofo
gorilla
in the history of any room what are they
going to get into next is a question i
mean they're just looking at whatever's
the biggest industry they want to get
into it
and they're doing a similar thing with
apple as well because
amazon is what apple is apple is the
phone you use but amazon is the store
you go to and by the way remember this
no one buys stuff on amazon on iphone
let me say that one more time you don't
buy stuff on
amazon's app because amazon doesn't sell
anything on their app
you know why they don't sell anything on
their app because they don't want to pay
the 30 to apple
everything you ever buy from amazon it's
from their
online amazon.com not from their app you
cannot buy a single product on amazon's
app
not one product did anybody know did you
know explain that to me because if i go
on my app what is it
you cannot buy and it'll take you
straight to amazon.com you cannot buy a
product on
amazon
what a brilliant thing he's got you
cannot buy amazon books
when you want to buy an amazon book you
have to go buy amazon book on amazon.com
audible and then it shows up on the
amazon app so they've figured out a way
to avoid having to pay that 30
yeah you got to give them credit they're
geniuses they are relentless
they are relentless how much is bezos
driving the ship as far as the strategy
and the planning is he still the guy
i i think he is the guy but at that
point have you guys read the book
no rules rules at netflix have you read
that book
it is a ridiculous book ridiculous book
that is so
unconventional and i bet it's the kind
of a book a boss doesn't want to give to
their employees you mean the ceo of
netflix wrote that yes he wrote it with
a critic
he wrote it with a critic that he said i
want to bring current and they went and
interviewed former employees who hated
netflix
and love netflix and they tell it all
every story goodbye ugly they tell it
and one thing one thing you notice when
when reed hastings talks about how he
manages his team
is it's at a point right now where you
simply pick a great team
and they go out and get the job done and
you kind of are monitoring it and some
of the bigger decisions run through you
one of his main guys that was going and
picking up the shows he is now the
co-ceo ted surrender is now the co-ceo
they just announced them i think july
or something like they became the co-ceo
netflix so you know
companies that size amazon listen you're
doing a trillion two trillion dollars a
year
when you're doing a couple trillion when
you do any kind of business that they're
two trillion dollar company
when you're doing as much business as
they're doing you're pretty much a small
country
yeah you're a country you're no longer a
business you are a country which means
you have governors you have senators you
have businessmen you have a lot of
different people
that help run uh the decisions but the
big one always comes through you so
what was the news uh speaking of how big
and bad they want to get there was ru
news a few weeks ago that they're
considering looking into buying cnn
something like that yes
it's a brilliant move by the way
somebody asked me would you buy cnn and
i said in a heartbeat i would buy cnn
uh uh uh see if you can get your hands
on cnn
you're it's a brilliant move look what
happened to fox look what happened to
fox fox is no longer far right wing
fox is no longer right wing fox is in
the middle today
fox's uh fox was the first that came out
with arizona before anybody else
yeah you know fox news came out and said
you know biden won arizona
and trump and all the people were pissed
off saying why are you reporting
fox is no longer what people thought fox
was pre
you know 2018 2017 viewers going over to
other stations i know you're a big cnn
but do you um no you're you're right i
mean their viewership has gone down
drastically and i think that's a that's
a like a litmus test for
you know politically when you get too
involved and you are not flexible
whatsoever in business in politics in
media
there will be repercussions down the
line and fox is seeing it right now
[Music]